you may soon see prices on
advertisements for prescription drugs
that would be a major change for the
drug industry and a lot of people are
very much against it obviously some are
for to try to drive drug prices down
let's talk about this with Health and
Human Services Secretary Alex azar mr.
secretary thanks for coming back special
report great to be here with Brett
what's the proposal here for this
regulation so what the president is
proposing is that drug companies would
have to put the list price of their
drugs in their TV ads so that way people
know how much a drug costs when they go
to see their doctor whether it's a $50
drug or a $5,000 drug they can factor
that into the discussion they're gonna
have with their doctors the president
said in May he wanted to bring this kind
of transparency and accountability to
the drug industry so that he could bring
drug prices down he's delivering on that
today so in addition to the guy that
talks fast at the end of the commercials
that says you know all these bad things
can happen to you they would say and by
the way it cost you 5,000 this will be
in print it'll say right there in print
this is the list price of this drug what
the monthly cost of this therapy or the
course of therapy will cost right there
and the purpose being competition the
purpose is competition the purpose is
the patient and the driver's seat
knowledgeable with critical information
where else in our world do we go in and
try to make a purchasing decision and we
don't know the price of the product
we're bringing that transparency so you
know and pharma doesn't want you to have
this information they've fought us and
president Trump is moving forward with
this anyways because he believes the
patient ought to be at the center and
have this information and drug prices
ought to come down you know that this
midterm election a lot of Democrats are
running on the issue of health care drug
prices as well but you look at Fox poll
number two on health care should the
government ensure more people spend more
64% Fox 3 president's handling of health
care approve disapprove 38% approve
disapprove 52% and which party would do
a better job on health care
Democrats 49% Republicans 34 I want you
to listen to some Democrats on this
issue
Arizonans
can't afford their healthcare some
people don't have it those who do have
it are paying too much
you said that we are gonna weaken
Medicare coverage for the elderly that
is an outrageous lie we expand coverage
to include dental care vision care and
hearing and hearing aids yes right and
this is really important to seniors so
talk from the administration's point of
view why voters should hand you the
baton again in both chambers of Congress
to handle the issue of health care well
I can't talk about the election but what
I can talk about is what we're doing to
help make healthcare more affordable for
the American people and president Trump
has been committed to making healthcare
more affordable and bring more choice
more transparent keep the patient in the
driver's seat people who are who are
promising Medicare for all that's one of
the big ideas now people keep talking
about Medicare for all is Medicare for
none you know these are the same people
who brought you Obamacare but this time
they're not even making the promise that
you can keep your health plan or you can
keep your doctor because they know
that's not the case the hundred and
seventy eight million of us who've got
employer insurance that would go away
under some of these proposals your
doctor you wouldn't get to keep your
doctor because your doctor would flee
these Medicare lower rates and we'd have
a two-tier system of health care where
they move into a cash system outside of
this Medicare so America's seniors would
lose their doctors they could lose their
hospitals they could lose the care
they've got you know the Democrats say
those are all scare tactics and talking
points and they look at the costs and
people are you know you ask people and
they're afraid of what's gonna happen
next I mean what is the administration
doing now with Congress or without
Congress to change that dynamic well
that's why the president's been so
committed to trying to bring health care
costs down whether it's a drug cost
which he's getting down and we're just
continuing to progress step-by-step
through to get drug costs down or on
health insurance where we're dealing
with the failed Obama care program for
the first time ever
Obama care plans the benchmark premium
is down almost two percent under
president Trump's leadership because the
state
belies the market it's still
unaffordable it still insurance people
don't necessarily want but he's at least
stabilized it and price came down for
the first time ever President Trump who
campaigned to get rid of Obamacare is
doing a better job managing Obamacare
than the guy who wrote the bill I want
to ask you one more question about the
border the president in the interview
was sixty minutes last night suggested
that the separation policy is under
review with parents and children do you
know where that stands tonight
well our immigration policies are
completely broken in this country and
Congress has got to act the president
has called on Congress to fix this
broken immigration system now we at the
Department of Health and Human Services
what we do is receive children who come
into this country unaccompanied migrant
children who've come in here illegally
they're given to us to provide a safe
and secure environment and what we do is
we work to find them vetted sponsors
usually these are family members already
in the country while they await their
adjudication proceedings that's the role
of HHS you know where your numbers are
tonight
we're we have over 13,000 unaccompanied
alien children in our custody right now
because of this broken immigration
system that is drawing these children to
come in this country they make they make
this horrible journey to try to get into
this country they come in illegally and
they're given over into our custody and
we've got to find a place to place to
put them into sponsorship here but with
their parents right now know they come
out of company these 13,000 are kids who
come into this country by themselves and
then they're given into our care and
we've got to try to find them sponsors
here in this country while we await the
broken immigration system to finally
adjudicate their case mr. secretary we
appreciate your time you're welcome back
any time